How to actually revise for GCSE science.
So school has just started,
and if you can do this from now,
you will do so amazing.
So let's say,
for example,
you have a biology paper 1 mock exam coming up.
So obviously
we know that the content on biology Paper 1
is B1 to B four.
Start off with B1.
Go to YouTube.
Such free science lessons.
B1 GCC playlist.
You'll get this playlist.
Watch every single video on this playlist,
and while you're watching it,
make flashcards.
So here I'm watching you carry out some prokaryotes.
I'm gonna write that on one side of the flashcard,
and then I'm gonna write the key notes
on the other side.
Like, for example,
prokaryotic cells are much smaller than
you carry out excels,
by the way. I got these flashcards from Tesco.
They're like
2 pounds. Okay,
now, once you finished watching
all of the videos in the playlist
and making all of the flashcards,
you now need to do active recall.
This is where you're gonna learn
everything on the flashcard off by heart.
Flip the flashcard upside down
so you can only see the topic name.
And then practice verbally, out loud,
all of the information on the actual flashcard.
And once you finish memorizing
the information on the flashcard,
move on to the next one.
And after you finish the whole of B1,
move on to the next topic.
So, like, B2B3.
Okay. And now
let's say you have A mock exam coming up in a month.
You already know all of the information on every topic
because you've done active recall.
So now what you need to do is pass papers
and practice questions.
So now it's all about application,
applying all of that knowledge.
You just need to do as many pass papers as you possibly
can before the exams.
And yeah, guys,
that's all you need to do for GCSE science.